foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello and welcome everybody
to daily with Doc so excited to have you
here with us as always and and yes it is
it's true excitement that we are able to
share empowering information with others
around the world meeting them where
they're at whether you're on YouTube or
rumble or Facebook or joining us here
live on our Zoom welcome to daily with
Doc my name is Becca dukes and as the
hostess of this program I am here
because of the impact that this
information that is going to be shared
with you today made on my own personal
life if I hadn't experienced it myself I
may not have believed it but folks when
you experience something that basically
gives you your life back and helps you
to look forward to it tomorrow to get
being old yeah I'm not getting old if I
look at pictures and then one of these
days I'm gonna have pictures I'm going
to show you side by side where I
actually look like I'm getting younger
and I feel younger a lot younger
and it's it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible what putting the right stuff
into the body and then the body just
loving it and utilizing it and doing
what it was designed to do when it has
the raw ingredients that it's supposed
to have to be able to generate
Moment by moment
healthy cells so just wanted to
do a quick little introduction as
everybody was coming into the room
if you're out on YouTube or rumble or
Facebook and you would like to join us
live you are more than welcome to we are
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12 50
ish
Pacific time
so go to daily with doczoom.com and join
us here live in the meeting room and
don't forget to go to daily with doc.com
you can sign up for our newsletter you
will receive a newsletter that gives you
information on how to connect with us it
will we are also sending out links with
descriptions to the last week's show so
if you're not able to join us each and
every day no Fred we send you out an
email that gives you links with
descriptions of what we talk about each
day delivered right to your email so I
love the fact that we're able to do that
we also have a newsletter that we are
putting articles together that's going
to also be information that you can use
and be empowered with in your own life
in your own family in your own community
and as we as individuals are working on
our own communities we're going to reach
the world in making sure that they also
have the information that they need to
reclaim health reclaim wellness and get
out of being dependent on Sick
management folks
so
the individual that we have with us each
and every day
Monday through Friday
is a lifer a 90 for lifer and it's not
just 90 for life or because of somebody
creating it he himself did the research
and found that there are about 90
essential nutrients essential meaning
our bodies cannot create it if we don't
put it in it doesn't get it and he's
going to tell us more about that
ladies and gentlemen I am honored to be
able to bring to you
Dr Joel Wallach Dr Wallach welcome to
daily with Doc well thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you team the whole
group we're just a family and we're here
to do great things to share with
everybody we can't thank you enough for
all you do to make it happen on Facebook
and YouTube and and uh once the other
ones
Rumble Rumble Rumble
and we've got other places we're going
to Dr Wally
so and then you know we're just on our
regular zoom and so we're very very
proud of that and so basically today I
want to talk about
connective tissue
um the biggest connective tissue mass in
the body is skin people don't think
about that but our skin you know from
the top of our head down to the tip of
the little toes onto your tips your
fingers your back and your fronts and
your belly and your lower back and so
forth that your skin is the biggest
connective tissue mass in the body and
then of course you have tendons and
ligaments and cartilage and bone matrix
your bones are not poured concrete
they're actually living tissue that come
and go based on the quality of your
nutrition and Rebecca had a history she
had bone spurs all over the place and
the doctors wanted to do all kinds of
surgery on her we put on the program and
her body repaired itself and all those
dozens and dozens and dozens of bone
spurs just went away because the bones
put them back where they belonged okay
and so these are the sort of things we
do using the knowledge we have about
what your tissues can do and then of
course there are certain things
the doctors say oh
um you'd have Lupus as a connective
tissue disease no connective tissue
disease is only part of it when you have
Lupus you have irritable bowel syndrome
which is a gluten thing you're not
absorbing nutrition you have a skin
issue you know dermatitis kind of thing
all over the place and then you also
have an emotional and mental problem and
it's an unimmune thing no you get off
all the bad foods you take your 90
essential nutrients and lupus goes away
in weeks I don't care if you've had it
for 20 years okay lupus is not an immune
thing it's a simple nutritional
deficiency
and then the same thing is true with
bone diseases arthritis osteoporosis uh
same thing with with vascular diseases
when you have things going on in your
veins varicose veins are all twisted up
and and saggy and everything like that
and then of course you have your
arteries closing up they have all the
sickness in the walls of the arteries
this is all due to inflammation to the
connective tissue in the walls of the
arteries and the veins
and this is easily reversible and
repairable you know by getting rid of
all the bad foods and taking the 90s
essential nutrients we'll get into the
specific nutrients in a minute
but just you know on the great scheme of
things
then there's tendons and ligaments
tendonitis oh my gosh uh bones are my
favorites um and particularly the skull
metal doctors don't even know anything
about the skull they don't realize that
we do have osteoporosis of the skull
which which produces 37 different
diseases and 17 of which are from the
skull down to the tips of your toes and
these you know they send you to like 15
different Specialists and they'll give
you hearing aids and surgeries and and
that kind of stuff that do a heart
transplant because as tense cranial
nerves being squeezed and so forth
um you do throat operations because the
ninth cranial nerve is being squeezed
and your voice changes you can't swallow
and all that kind of stuff
and then you have you're slowly losing
your vision
and they're going to give you
um eye surgery because the skull is
squeezing the the optic nerve
and also squeezing the optic artery and
optic vein
okay
and then causing really damage to the
retina the line of the eye
it's worthy
um optic nerve going to the back of the
eye called the the retina okay is the
membrane and then the zone is called the
macula so when you have macular
degeneration the blood supply to the
macula is being shut off because your
skull is squeezing the optic nerve the
optic or the optic vein and they would
do all these surgeries and all this and
the other when really all you do is
change your diet and take your 90
essential nutrients repair your skull
and repair your brain repair your optic
nerve your optic vein your optic artery
and the stuff all goes away and I'm you
know very very
happy about those things and so
um let's see here
um
it's one of those things where again
before you get a double knee replacement
give us 90 days before you do a double
hip replacement give us 90 days before
you do a back surgery give us 90 days
before you do amputations the toes and
fingers give us 90 days before you have
all these massive
operations because you get
um bone spurs all over the place give us
90 days first you have rheumatoid
arthritis give us 90 days okay because
rheumatoid arthritis is just nutritional
deficiency here arthritis for the
secondary infection with a bug called
mycoplasma which is killable with an
antibody called Minocycline like the
little Bait fish minnow minnow cycling
will kill that bug and you get on the
healthy Bone and Joint pack and your
rheumatoid arthritis goes away in weeks
I don't care if you've had it for 25
years it'll go away it's not autoimmune
like your doctors say okay with all that
sort of as a preamble uh I'm going to
turn this over to Rebecca so she can ask
me some questions on the subjects
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
that's a sh that's I think that's the
shortest intro you have ever again given
but that's okay because we have so many
people that are writing in through email
we have people here in the live Zoom
with us with their hands up and
questions and
you had mentioned the skin
being the largest mass of connective
tissue
us all together
you know this together and protects us
from outside forces okay and
um again it requires all 90 essential
nutrients in the blood supply just like
all other tissues and so when people get
eczema dermatitis psoriasis psoriatic
arthritis
um
the skin ulcers they have skin blisters
they get all kinds of stuff all over the
place they lose pigment in the skin if
you're a person of color you can lose
the pigment in your skin okay and you
get a little white spots all over the
place your hair color goes away you get
white gray and silver hair this is not
due to aging this is due to nutritional
deficiencies
okay and so this is all easily
reversible
this is all easy reversible I don't care
what what race of people should come
from let's say your hair is turning
white and silver and you're getting big
patches where you're losing your skin
color let's get on the program here with
the healthy brain and heart pack the MSM
collagen peptides you need to get the
ultimate daily classic tablets for
circulation into the skin ultimate daily
Classics has three words I take three of
those twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight and then we do have hair skin and
Nails you can take three of those or
three times a day if you really have a
heavy duty skin problem
and the skin heals extremely quickly
because it has an enormous blood supply
good stuff coming in there but it does
need the raw materials to be brought to
it for it to be able to heal itself
and so we see this literally thousands
of times a month all over the world skin
is easy to heal
okay
and you know there's exceptions of skin
cancer is a dangerous thing and Cancers
um which I say you know you have these
little skin cancers the size of a pee
those are the sort of things you can
have them surgically removed but why did
you have that skin cancer okay that
means you're you're in contact with some
toxic stuff somewhere either in your
diet or in your environment and so you
need to check all that out and find out
what caused that skin cancer so you
don't keep getting them and so forth oh
yeah I just get them getting removed and
three months later I don't have another
one well that means you haven't dealt
with the cause of that skin cancer and
that's why they keep coming back
but when it comes to other things just
psoriasis dry itchy skin
um
blisters
color loss
um
alopecia where you're losing your hair
hair goes away I have people who were
bald for 40 50 years and just after two
months in our program they started
growing hair and in three months time
they had a head of hair like a 12 year
old hippie okay
so when something is because of a
nutrient deficiency Dr Wallach the the
body was innately designed that when it
has the ingredients and you're supposed
to have hair in those areas
then it is possible that the body can
reproduce it it can regrow hair also it
can regrow bone let's say you know again
the doctors say you know you don't have
any cartilage in your joints we're gonna
have to do a double knee replacement
double hip replacement say well give me
90 days first and the doctor will say
why do you say that well you know
there's a thing out there that's going
around that maybe I can regrow the
cartilage oh no no no that's just on yes
give us 90 days because we can regrow
cartilage I don't care if you've had
bone to bone arthritis and and your
knees you just have so much pain in your
knees you're using a walker and so often
you're clicking and popping even with
the Walker well it's one of those things
where you give your body the raw
materials you got to give up the bad
stuff
so you can absorb no no fried foods no
processed meats you know we're talking
bacon and ham and hot dogs and bologna
and salami and pepperoni and that sort
of stuff absolutely no wheat bun around
those well my doctor says eat more whole
grains we're doctors wrong you want to
eat rice many beans okay that's fine if
you want to eat corn once well boiled
corn and roasted corn is fine don't be
any fried corn okay
and so it's one of those things where
there's no gluten in corn okay but there
is gluten in Wheat by the Rhinos well my
doctor says there's no gluten in oats
well the gluten oats is called gliadin
okay it's still gluten okay is a
um a bullet the same thing as a
projectile yeah he'll still kill you and
it has a little different name okay so
the same thing is true here with these
issues when it comes to health and
depending on what school they went to
and so further what they're going to
call it but give us 90 days as we always
say give us 90 days because you will see
significant Improvement or complete
resolution
okay
something you know regrowing bone I just
want to clarify folks if you've had an
amputation of a foot or a toe you're not
going to regrow your foot or your toe
back that's correct
so I just wanted I just wanted to add
that little clarification in there doc
you have to give your body what it needs
before you cut the leg off
and she is 62 years old with psoriasis
since she was three years old
on her buttocks torso and legs mostly
so she says that she exercises she eats
right she's in good health other than
the psoriasis so Dr Wallach the
psoriasis fall Within
nutritional deficiencies yeah racist is
a very very simple skin deficiency
nutritional deficiency okay you can have
patches your whole body can be covered
with dry flaky skin cracking skin
psoriasis okay saggy skin wrinkled skin
there's all kinds of variations on that
but it's an essential
nutrient deficiency okay so she said
wait how much
um she's 62 years old she doesn't give a
weight so let's just go buy 100 pounds
okay per 100 pounds we're talking about
for psoriasis whether it's a little
Patch the size of a quarter or a Patch
the size of a basketball or if it's a
whole body
but she said on her butt her legs and
her torso so it could be small patches
but it's all over Okay so
basically she needs to get it again get
rid of all the bad twos and maximize
absorption no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils uh no cooking oils no
salad dressings I like to use lemon
wedges and squirt lemon juice on my
salads I also like if it's just it's a
type of cell that requires a creamy
dressing I like to use the um yogurt
okay as the dressing as opposed to oily
dressings uh absolutely no gluten no
wheat no by rhinos even if your doctor
says eat more whole eat more whole
grains eat rice okay
um do not eat wheat bread rare oats and
then I also want you to give up
buckwheat buckwheat doesn't have any
gluten in it they brag about big things
on the label no gluten which is true but
it does have another compound called
fago f-a-g-o Pyrenees fago Pyrenees
which is worse than glutens okay so you
got to stay away from buckwheat then no
sugar and absolutely no carbon in your
drinks even the diet one's got to go and
also the carbonated water because they
have the bubbling and they neutralize
your stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals or digest food so even bubbly
water is dangerous okay don't do that
okay I know little kids like that but
don't don't give them the bubbly Waters
okay and then let's see we do have in
our rebounds four shrink uh the cans are
bubbly but I like to pop the tops on
them the night before I'm going to drink
them put them in the refrigerator they
off gas all the bubbly at night they're
flat in the morning so I'll have one at
breakfast one at lunch time but we do
have the sticks
um which has 100 nutrients in a stick
and there's 30 of these sticks in a box
we have the canister there's 36 servings
in the canister and again there's a
little scoop in there and each scoop is
one you know has a hundred nutrients in
it
I'm going to turn right here
there
you go there you go okay so anyway we
have all this stuff that's gonna uh help
the skin help the blood vessels help the
energy
and
just
um
have I missed any skin things here
Rebecca
well the skin there's a lot of things
that can go wrong with the skin doctor
wallet I don't know I mean as far as the
products as far as the products oh yeah
we have more and one of my favorites Dr
Wallach is our skin care and our makeup
and the things that we can do topically
just to make us feel good smell good
without having all the toxins but as far
as a protocol for
Joanne you've got it
okay
so
let's go
yeah talking about skin doctor well like
so Annie is on YouTube with us and she's
wanting to know what if you lost your
hair due to a toxicity of a nutrient
like selenium how long does it take the
body to get rid of excess
selenium well and what would you do well
I don't know who told you selenium
causes hair loss that's not true
okay
that's just what the question says so
it's nice I know but okay yeah selenium
is an essential nutrient it's the
favorite nutrient of your heart it's the
favorite nutrient of your liver why do
all these young athletes die on their
teens and 20s and 30s from sudden heart
death
okay because of your deficiency of uh
selenium what causes sediment death
syndrome SIDS it wasn't the mothers
laying on the babies it was a lack of
the selenium in the baby formulas
because doctors kept it out of baby
formulas because they falsely believed
it was poisonous
and that falls into the science of
crampola can I say crampola
you can say crapola okay okay so yeah I
won't censor you for that
selenium is an essential nutrient don't
go there don't go there selenium is an
essential nutrient it's required by all
your tissues of the body but it's
particularly important for the brain the
heart the liver blood vessels
muscles they said their skeletal muscles
your bone marrow selenium is so
important
um
I and of course our great attorney
Jonathan emo and I we sued the FDA Food
and Drug Administration eight times in
federal court to get these nutrients put
into baby formulas and we eliminate it
and sediment death syndrome in 90 days
by getting it put into the baby formulas
now for years and years and years and
years and years and years and years
years doctors have been telling people
that mothers who are laying on the
babies and suffocating on them and
that's that's what was causing the
the sentiment death syndrome was the
mother's lane or the babies and
suffocate no it was just a simple
nutritional deficiency because the baby
Farmers didn't have it in there and the
mothers if they were breastfeeding the
babies and the baby died of of the um
cinnamon syndrome the mothers were
eating gluten we'd brought around oats
and not supplementing properly and so
the baby even though breast milk was not
getting the nutrition necessary to
prevent cinnamon death syndrome okay
this is very simple stuff
okay thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach now I know that there's
different forms of calcium are there
different forms of selenium
well selenium that can be found you know
in soil as just like you can find iron
and copper and and those kinds of things
um selenium
um I think if you make a bullet out of
it and shoot yourself with it it'll be
fatal
well I know on the hair analysis it is
not listed in the toxic Metals
you know minerals so so that that was a
good sign there so I just wanted to ask
um
so Dr Wallach let's go to the next hand
that is up where the first hand that is
up here
um in the zoom room with us and we have
a newcomer uh Ryan T
go ahead and unmute yourself if you can
come on camera with us that would be
fantastic if not you in you're still on
with Dr Wallach go ahead and unmute
yourself
um I sorry I like it's a coincidence
um wait sorry can you hear me hear me
yes we can hear you great Ryan go ahead
sorry um I was away for a moment
um like 30 seconds ago
um well did I miss something
go ahead you're up you have your hand up
do you have a question millions of
people listening to you talk talk
we're good we're here for everybody go
ahead Ryan okay um currently I am taking
currently I am taking one capful of um
Ultimate Classic liquid
um to Capital capfuls of plant-derived
minerals uh non-youngeety supplements
equivalent to the dose suggested to me
in December uh excluding the um and
regarding um blood sugar uh one sweeties
and chromium piccolonate uh I I'm not
taking any Wheats or any soy sauce which
contains wheat
um compared to December uh my
hypoglycemia and varicose veins are more
manageable
um however um currently my primary
concern now is osteoporosis uh because
in January I stopped taking Audio FX
because I tinnitus began to increase and
um my teeth began to move more so I
resumed my old um calcium citrate and
magnesium supplementation uh in March I
submitted the hair sample uh but two
weeks ago um before I received a hair
sample I was experimenting by um mega
dosing a new a new one calcium glycinate
uh 2.7 grams calcium to 1.5 grams of
magnesium
but that was a fatal mistake and I'm not
fatal but I I began to have many
Concepts like uh tartar
um slight angina diarrhea um okay back
up there stop there for a minute that's
a good example for other people you
don't want to take a lot of one nutrient
you want to take the optimal amounts of
all nutrients okay it's a big mistake
and that's why we don't talk about oh
well what can I do for my arthritis we
give you a program
was 90 to 215 nutrients in it so it's
taking care of all those relationships
as opposed to saying oh take lots of
calcium
okay you do that you're gonna you're
going to
eliminate the ability to utilize all the
other nutrients and you wind up with 15
new diseases you never had before when
you take you know too much of one
nutrient and so that's why it's kind of
like when you're baking a cake you know
there's all the the recipe you had to
follow the recipe was a couple of this a
spoonful of that just as the recipe says
you can't just say well I'm just gonna
take a big big big quart of wheat flour
and put that in the oven and make my
cake well you're not going to get a cake
doing that okay you have to do the
recipe with all the all the ingredients
in the proper relationships they've been
determined by time and and a lot of you
know individuals or experts in making a
cakes okay and so it's one of those
things where you can't play with one
nutrient
do not play with one nutrient okay
that's why we have the books that's why
we have the CDs
um and it wouldn't hurt if you haven't
done it get the book rare Earth's been
cures go to chapter 10 11 page 272 and
get a hair analysis and find out where
you're at when it comes to your
nutritional minerals your toxic minerals
and everything that will give you a clue
what's going on you can't tell
by your clinical things going on because
some of them are masked by the more
painful ones so you want to get that
hair analysis
uh it'll tell you in in the book where
to send the check and the hair sample
and so forth how to collect it how to
package it where to ship it don't forget
to put the check in there if you're in a
foreign country don't forget to put a
money order in there the lab won't run
the test without the money
and usually within two to three weeks
you're
um
gonna get the hair analysis back you'll
get like five or six charts two of the
main charts and one chart is the the
nutritional minerals where are you at
there okay and then also the second
essential chart in there is toxic
minerals where you're at there okay and
it's one of those things where where the
um the dad is unimpeachable
and then of course we have you know if
you have toxic Metals at dangerous
levels we have the herbal rainforest as
a detox okay and we'll tell you how much
use of that per you know per 100 pounds
of body weight and so forth to get rid
of the toxic metals and if you're
missing a few of the nutritional
minerals that's because you're just
eating and you're not getting enough out
of your food nutritional minerals are
not attorney uniform blanket around the
trust of the earth they current veins
like gold and silver and so the only way
you're going to maximize your nutrients
the only way you're going to get each
and every one of a monopoly ounce is to
supplement with all of them
and people's well I don't want to do
that well it's this is America you have
your choice you do what you want okay
but um uh
which I say you know if you're not
taking all 90 essential nutrients in a
fashion in which you can absorb them
with your diet and so forth uh you will
pay a horrible price okay I'm not only
talking about money I'm talking about
losing
many years of healthful life
and having to pay pay a lot of money to
deal with things that happen that didn't
need to happen okay
so Dr Wallach what would you recommend
for somebody that has been told that
they have osteoporosis they have the
ringing in the ears or tinnitus tinnitus
whatever part of the country you're
calling from
what would you recommend for them so
we've got the osteoporosis of the skull
protocol you can find in the book
exactly what happens when you have
osteoporosis of the skull and all the
different conditions that are associated
and this is only a partial partial list
of the two conditions that Dr Wallach
has found to be
associated with osteoporosis of the
skull I had three quarters of these Dr
Wallach wow thankfully I don't have any
of them now
and the fact that I followed your
program and I stuck to it yes there were
times where I was thinking this isn't
working but it was only for a day or two
and I kept going and I'm so glad that I
did
so in addition to the brain and heart
Dr Wallach and this is per 100
pounds you recommend the MSM Ultra
and if severe cases that's two bottles
so that you can take three three times a
day
and then the collagen peptides
and that's two canisters right so you
can have stupid morning stupid evening
and don't forget the rebounders for
Strings as opposed to soft drinks and
carbonated water juices and all that
kind of stuff
100 nutrients in there are 75 minerals
and 25 bottoms amino acids very very
important
um I do that and I only weigh 142 pounds
and I get 100 nutrients four times a day
okay because I'm taking all this stuff
and uh in a couple of months I'll be 84
and it's one of those things where
most people can't imagine me being 84
because you know I look and act like I'm
50 years old or so okay
it's one of those things where this is
unimpeachable we have literally
thousands of people in the youngeot
family
who have followed our protocol and have
gotten benefits and total reversals of
horrible horrible things in their skin
and their tendons and ligaments and
connective tissues and heart valves
and a skull and every place where
there's connective tissue your bones are
not supposed to concrete your bones are
minerals put onto a sort of give and
take Matrix skeleton of a connective
tissue
okay
it's called Matrix bone matrix it's it's
cartilage that's why we used to make
um
bone broth we boil the bones in vinegar
on a wood stove overnight so it would
suck all the minerals out of the bones
and we would drink that and we get our
minerals that way it was too messy and
stinky and smelly so that's why we came
up with the actual and to replace the
bone broth we came up was the MSM and
the
um let's see here this the collagen
peptides
and the glucogel and all that kind of
stuff
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach
um so folks it's not a little bit of
this a little bit of that
it's getting the body all of the
nutrients that it needs and the
cofactors that are put into the formula
is that Dr Wallach is recommending they
synergistically work together
and it's in a form that the body can
actually absorb
so that's one thing that I think worked
best for me and you can find the story
in the book that Dr Wallach is holding
up right now Wallach Revolution you can
find Dr wallach's books at d r j
wallick.com that's
d-r-j w a l l a c
h.com and you'll find Allah Dr wallach's
Publications there so Ryan thank you so
much for the question and giving us the
opportunity to be able to address that
in taking high doses of individual
nutrients because Dr Wall like I did it
myself
thinking that that was the right thing
to do and and it gave me some really bad
digestive results
um
where yeah when you talk about irritable
bowel syndrome you don't go back there
yeah I'm not going back
so we have Marilyn who has her hand up
Marilyn
go ahead and unmute yourself and before
you say anything Marilyn I just want to
make sure that everybody who's here with
us if you have a question for Dr Wallach
find that raised hand in the zoom menu
you'll be able to raise your hand if
you're out on YouTube or rumble or
Facebook we do have members of my team
monitoring the chat there so that we can
get your questions answered there as
well so don't be afraid don't be scared
go ahead and ask your questions and if
we do not get to your question during
the time of the program then feel free
to reach out to us on daily with doc.com
use that contact us but if you were
invited by somebody specific get back
with them they took the time to share
this program with you and chances are
really good that they also are
associated with us and I have many of
the people that are on this team and
many of the people that are commenting
who are also certified holistic health
coaches so they've been trained to help
you get exactly what you need
to meet your health goals okay Marilyn
I'm done talking for a moment go ahead
okay
um I have a question in the chat from MD
and he's been on the program I'm
assuming it's our program for tinnitus
and he says it's better but it's not
gone he's added MSM and synaptic
but he wants to know how long it will be
till it will go away
do we have a weight
I do not I wonder if we could get him on
let's go for 150 pounds doc okay let's
go for 150 pounds okay so
um he needs to get rid of all the bad
foods
um don't listen to your doctor he's
saying eat more whole grains Okay no
wheat butter and oats no wheat bun
around oats no buckwheat no fried foods
no processed Meats absolutely no sugar
no carbonated drinks even carbonated
water needs to go because it neutralizes
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals or digest food okay if you have
tinnitus or tinnitus as nasty approaches
to the skull squeezing the auditory
branch of the eighth cranial nerve you
need to get a hold of the book
uh it's all in your head okay and
there's 12 chapters okay and each
chapter goes from one of the 12 cranial
nerves and there's a set on the right
hand side of your soul on the side of
the left hand side of the skull and then
um
we have a CD that goes along with it
okay it's a set and this is the normal
skull a quarter of an inch thick and a
human being this is the skull without
osteoporosis it's an inch and a half to
two inches thick you can see we're just
squeezing the 12 pairs of cranial nerves
and squeezing the spinal cord there you
go thank you and it's one of those
things
it's unimpeachable evidence okay that
this is a mechanical issue it's not an
autoimmune thing so uh 150 pounds we get
rid of all the bad foods
and to have two healthy branded heart
packs per month two how they painted
hard passion about the photos everything
twice a day I'm going to have two
bottles a month of the MSM saying take
um three of breakfast sweet lunch free
dinner time they're going to support and
promote Mains repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone range about himself
including the skull
then you need to take the
um uh let's see here collagen peptides
take a take a scoop of that in the
morning drinks with an evening drink
that will be two of those small
canisters a month to pull that off and
help rebuild the skull the skull over a
period of 90 days to a couple of months
the skill will go down to the normal
size and take the pressure off those
nerves
and
um then let's see here also needs to
have vitamin D3 even if they live in
Florida or California Southern
California they don't get in a bikini
and lay out in the sun
you know for three hours a day so they
need to have the vitamin D3 to make sure
they're getting the minerals absorbed
and put in the proper places
um
the need to take
um let's see here and also have them
take the rebounders for a shrink instead
of all those soft drinks and juices and
that kind of coffee coffee coffee coffee
coffee okay we we sell coffee there's
nothing wrong with a cup of two of
coffee a day but if you're drinking six
cups of coffee and you're not drinking
your rebound
um yeah our coffee has more minerals in
it than anybody else's coffee because we
use our blooming minerals fertilizer in
our coffee plantation we have a coffee
plantation and we use our blooming
minerals there so our coffee has more
minerals in it than anybody else's
coffee but still I want you to use you
know you know two two three four cups of
coffee a day for a 200 pound person is
okay a day but make sure you're also
having at least two servings a day of
the
um of the rebound okay but tonight goes
away very quickly it's not aging it's
honestly a process of the skull
squeezing the auditory branch of the
atrial nerve it goes away very quickly
when you do this how long do you have to
stay on the program
as long as you're breathing oxygen if
you die you don't need to worry about it
but if you're still alive you want to be
making sure that all this is good
because you're just seeing a symptom of
one cranial nerve being squeezed but I
guarantee the others are being squeezed
also and it may kill say well yeah you
know my voice is changing and I have
hiccups well that's the ninth trailer
being squeezed and the tenth crayon are
being squeezed and my my doctor wants to
give me an ablation or a heart
transplant because I have atrial
fibrillation well it's not a heart
disease it's the skull squeezing the
tense cranial nerve the vagus nerve
causing that and that all goes away
give us 90 days on our program as we say
it should be done and guess what you
will be blessed
okay
um you had mentioned that if people try
to supplement with calcium if they don't
address the nutrients for the bone
matrix first they can't absorb the
calcium or the body won't utilize the
calcium well well you might be able to
absorb it but where is it going to be
put see the calcium gets put on the bone
matrix which is the skeleton of the
skeleton okay which is the the soft
connective tissue it's like tendon like
materials like your skin and um just
like your fingernails if you don't have
skin where your fingernail is going to
go okay
it's one of them if you don't have skin
you're not going to have hair
and so they're all related and again
your skin is your biggest
reservoir of connective tissue in your
whole body
excellent thank you
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and next we're going to move right over
to Ruth Ellen who has her hand up Ruth
Ellen do you have a question for us
and you are muted
hello I'm Dr Wallach and well
um I have a question from email
and
um I have no information about the
person they just their name is Carol and
she sent in an email and it says lack of
pin pigmentation spots slash patches
after chemo
is there anything that can be eaten or
creamed to be used to bring back
pigmentation after receiving chemo
um and then she says with eating tons of
carrots help question mark and
what would be a great program for Carol
Dr Wallach
okay well that's good we I guess we got
to go by 100 pounds because you didn't
right I have no information that was the
entirety of the email okay so let's go
when you have a loss of skin pigment
whether it's just happening or it
happens following some kind of medical
uh chemotherapy or medical procedures or
something like that or could be due to
quote aging unquote but usually it's
caused by lack of nutrients okay and so
when people have serious health problems
it's lack of nutrients okay so you need
to get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat nobody around oats no
sugar no buckwheat no carbonator drinks
um you know the diet drinks and the
carbonated water got to go and then per
100 pounds of body weight one healthy
brain and heart pack per month
um let's see here also one of the MS
bottles of the MSM so you take three
twice a day that's going to support and
promote mainstream pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
including in the skin uh you want the
Hair Skin Nails I'd go with um three of
those bottles a month so you can take
three breakfast sweet lunch at dinner
time and that's going to give the skin
the raw materials it needs for hair
um hair regrowth also because a lot of
people will lose uh hair when they get
chemotherapy and so forth
hair regrowth skin pigmentation
and also the um if they only weigh 100
pounds they're only going to get one
Pilgrim hard pack I would also get to
two more bottles of slim if they had
cancer treatment uh the cofactors that
come along with arsene not everybody's
sleep but honestly we have five
cofactors go along one of those
cofactors is actually uh required to
make a connective tissue
um in the arteries in the walls of of
the veins and arteries also in your skin
your bones and so forth and so it's one
of those things where
um it's imperative to make sure you get
all that but also
will actually
encourage the skin to produce
hair color again and also skin color
again hair color comes back and skin
color comes back
but you do have to take the total
program that held the brain and heart
pack of the MSM or the collagen peptides
and then of course the MSM and if they
have habit pressure our artery blocked
artery problems they need to take the
ultimate daily classic tapestry words
ultimate daily classic tablets
um take three of those twice a day and
it'll get this the blood flow through
blocked arteries everywhere in the skin
in the hearts and the kidneys and the
liver the brain
and so it's one of those things where
um you need all 90 essential nutrients
to make these things happen Okay so
that's why we kind of go with these
programs as opposed to saying oh just
take more calcium no that will lose
every time
okay thank you so much you bet
all right thank you Dr Wallach and let's
go ahead and I have a question coming in
from email this is coming from South
Africa and the question and we've
mentioned teeth a couple times today the
question is can there be healing or
restoration come to a person's teeth
through correct nutrition
so I also have another one that talks
about teeth being shaky and loose
um those are all part of osteoporosis of
the skull whenever you've got the loose
teeth
but what can we do for like the
structure of the tooth is that possible
well you get an A plus and of course the
structure that sees is dealt with from
the internal part of the tooth where the
blood vessels you know the arteries come
in and the veins come out and so forth
and
um I haven't seen a lot of redrawing
fragile teeth but I have seen a lot of
where teeth are loose and twisting
around and all that kind of stuff and
flapping in the breeze that you can
rebuild the jaw the upper you know
Dental arcade in the skull and also in
your Jawbone you can rebuild that and
tightening up on the teeth
and so it's one of those things or
wouldn't hurt to go to a dentist and ask
them to do an examination and say what's
going on here why are my teeth loose can
I rebuild teeth can I tighten up my jaw
so I can maintain my teeth and if you go
to a dentist that does things for kids
you know they go to one of these
orthodontists that did put braces on
kids and things that's where I'd go I'd
ask an orthodontist those questions okay
and they will give you some good
information
but um
one thing about an orthodontist is they
can straighten them up and then as
you're taking the nutrients and
rebuilding the bone structure
you know tighten them right up tighten
them right up
awesome thank you so much Dr Wallach
let's go ahead and move right over to
Farhan Farhan go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello can you guys hear me yes sir
sounds great okay great uh so Dr Wallach
I have someone I know he's 27 years old
he is
about 165 pounds
and uh so he has AFib
he has anxiety
and he can't even though he rests really
well and he's have several sleep studies
he can't he's always tired
yeah I guess yeah okay so yeah he's got
165 pounds he needs to get rid of all
the bad foods okay no fried foods no
processed meat no oils or glutens no
wheat to buy around those so sugar no
buckwheat no carbon or drinks even the
carbonated water needs to go and
whenever you have
um and see here
uh afib atrial fibrillation that's the
tense cranial nerve aka the vagus nerve
being squeezed by the skull it's
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
10th cranial nerve it's not a heart
problem okay atrial fibrillation is
being told uh it's hard to do that and
the doctors want to give them medication
but they really really want to
anesthetize them open up their chest
take the heart out take a hot Branding
Iron touch it all over the heart so to
find the place that's making the heart
do irregular heartbeats it that afib
treatment okay ablation is called
um it should be called extermination
because it has the highest death rate of
any medical treatment
you do not want to agree to and
volunteer for ablation okay do not do
that when you have that eraser heartbeat
but again
um
the
165 pounds to healthy branded heart
packs two with bottles of MSM uh take a
photo of everything twice a day both of
those other collagen peptides two of the
canisters and take a full dose uh scoop
and breakfast school at dinner time also
need the vitamin D3 through those twice
today uh need the
synaptive uh three of those twice today
two bottles a month so the brain cells
can talk to each other okay and then it
wouldn't hurt to take the ultimate daily
classic tablets have three words
ultimate daily classic cows to get the
blood flowing into the heart blood
flowing into the brain blood flowing
into the skull
and um
this all goes away
these are just simple nutritional
deficiency problems
what do you think that could be causing
the tiredness even though he gets good
sleep okay always tired okay well we do
have a sleepies you could go ahead and
take a you know a dose of sleepies a
half hour before bed time uh do that
also has to stay away from sugar
and I'm comparison to the gluten so it
can absorb the nutrients
no sugar
um because that accelerates you no
alcohol because that accelerates you you
got to watch that before bedtime
and um
that's that's you know you have to
change his diet because the diet is
contributing heavily to all the things
that are going wrong here including the
Sleep issue it wouldn't hurt also for
him to get to two pounds a month for a
sweetie so he can take three at
breakfast three dinner time because do
we know when he eats a big heavy dinner
time does he fall asleep watching TV an
hour later
well he said that is I asked him do you
have a blood sugar problem he said no he
does a lot of blood tests or they you
know he's been a doctor so many times he
says he's normal blood test unless
you're looking for hypoglycemia okay
they're not going to be able to it's a
10 hour test
okay just taking a blood test oh your
blood blood sugar is normal you can't
tell there you got to eat a big heavy
meal with lots of carbohydrates like
spaghetti something like that or a big
breakfast with pancakes and then an hour
later you just fall asleep you could be
driving you could be watching TV you
could be playing Racquetball and just
dropped your knees and fall asleep and
fall on your face okay because your
blood sugar goes so low you fall asleep
and so he could have a blood sugar
problem and he doesn't have to go to a
doctor or get permission to find out he
can go to a pharmacy without a
prescription get the test strips
now you can also get the test strips for
urine see if there's any sugar in the
urine all that kind of stuff not if he
has a sugar problem okay
sounds great thank you yeah let us know
all right thank you Farhan now Dr
Wallach
um there is a follow-up question for
Ryan and Ryan wants to know because he
has a hyperparathyroid
well how would you address that I just
wanted to know because he has the
elevator he did the hair analysis
and in the hair analysis it showed that
he had a high ratio of the calcium and
magnesium
so the problem is the calcium is being
pulled out of his bones because of the
parathyroid is perceiving
they're not getting enough calcium so
he's trying to maintain the blood
calcium that's why that's happening okay
so got to get rid of all the bad foods
take all the 90 essential nutrients and
you know and so forth stay away from the
bad foods and
um wouldn't hurt to throw in the
ultimate enzymes to take two of those
say
Farm to 10 minutes for each meals you
know it's a big bottle so one bottle
should last them a month
two before each meal
and the ultimate enzymes and that should
help absorption of nutrients but stay
away from
you know carbohydrates with every meal
stay away from carbohydrate you know you
can't have
um uh rice pancakes for breakfast and
rice noodles for lunch and rice for
dinner or baked potatoes for dinner and
have you know carbohydrates with every
meal okay because that drives your your
system to go One Direction there
I'm glad that you added that rice in
there Dr Wallach because you had just
said if somebody eats a big whole bunch
of spaghetti and all these other things
these things that you say do not eat
there are gluten-free options
I love the fact that there's gluten-free
options but that doesn't mean that we
can still hold on and Gorge
overdue
carbohydrates in general whether they're
rice or not but there are healthier
options too things that are wheat barley
Rye oats or spelled or wheat buckwheat
yep all of these different grains that
have been pushed for so long to be quote
unquote healthy have actually created a
decline in health worldwide and Dr
Wallach you do have another program to
get to we just thank you again
for joining us thank you
over and out we will see you tomorrow Dr
Wallach and folks just as a reminder
dealing with Doc is a Monday through
Friday program where you are able to
join us for empowering information that
allows you to be able to regain or take
control or maintain
your Wellness we're not about Sick
management we want to promote and give
the body what it needs to be able to not
just survive but actually Thrive if I
could get my co-hosts to join me here on
the screen I just want to give them a
big old shout out we've had a lot of
stuff going on folks we've got questions
I think on all three platforms plus here
in the zoom menu
um and it does take a community it takes
a crew of like-minded people to make a
show like this happen and it's not just
the show to happen it's to impact
communities impact lives and through the
impact that we ourselves have felt we
can without a doubt share this
information to help others as well so on
behalf of daily with Doc
as the hostess I want to give a big old
shout out to my co-hosts Phyllis and
Sherry and Farhan and Marilyn and Ruth
Allen and Heather who's not on camera
with us but making sure that the other
cameras and everything are
doing what they're supposed to do there
she is
um and folks if you want to be part of a
community
there's room
we have billions of people around the
world
and only about a hundred thousand
youngevity Associates so there is room
for you we are not about who can get the
most and out doing the next person
that's not about what our community is
we are about working together helping
each other succeed because when I help
others succeed that helps me succeed I'm
doing what I have the purpose to do and
that's helped people find health help
people regain their health and feel the
difference that I felt
get back with the person that shared
this program with you ask him if they
know of a way that you can fit into a
community and use your skills to help
build healthier communities
on behalf of again
daily with Doc if you have never spoken
with anybody ever about the youngevity
products Dr Wallach
or anything youngevity
feel free to use our number
855-949-3377 I do have a call team that
is standing by to take your calls again
that is eight five five
949-3377 until next time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]